all right Noah to movies mmm what's
going on what's happening uh-huh
how did this happen I don't know I just
woke up one day and well come here at
the same time are you gonna be
celebrating sure I mean I you know I
think just just the just the concept of
work that I've done coming out and being
received by audiences yes enough
celebration and what was life like
before this moment oh yeah exactly yeah
I mean today today I woke up and I came
to the four seasons and obviously the
actions of today have been very
different but the only thing that's that
I feel is really changes the outside
circumstances and those haven't even
changed that much yet I got stalked when
I went to New York that was cool tell us
about that stalked I like digitally
you're like like I posted on Instagram
that I was gonna be in New York and when
I landed they these people somehow
figured out that I was gonna do work I
wasn't going to LaGuardia I was flying
into JFK oh they were there at baggage
claim waiting for me and then they like
followed me to my hotel in a car and we
had to lose them before I got to the
hotel did you just say life hasn't
changed because that sounds kind of
that's externally you know but yes I you
know I take it back life has changed yes
for sure
in little ways and but I also recognize
that that's love you know that was all
love they're excited so let's talk about
Sierra Burgess is a loser your character
in that have you ever first of all have
you ever been catfished have you ever
watched catfish before never seen I've
never seen the show no but I mean yeah I
think I think a while ago
yeah I've been before and what can you
pull from that character that maybe you
experienced in your high school life
well I think I think if you ever develop
some sort of relationship or a sensible
intimate relationship with someone over
the Internet and then you find out that
they're not who you thought they were
you do feel it a little violated which
is how Jamie felt you know that when you
finally realized what he realized and
then so I guess you could pull from that
for sure I mean it's kind of case in
case yeah and in high school I mean
obviously the theme of
movie it's just high school stuff was
high school tough for you at all you
know I wasn't in high school for very
long middle school was tough yeah for me
eighth grade was tough for me and then I
went to high school I I took what I
learned in eighth grade and like applied
it and I just sat in the back of the
class and slept you know I didn't really
talk to nobody in high school
great just fun facts know what thanks
buddy is there like a theme from that
movie that you're hoping would inspire
people or people will take away from
from Sara Burgess yeah yeah yeah I mean
what out wish people would receive from
it is to not let society or culture
dictated to find beauty love or or your
interests or your likes or dislikes like
please go out experience the world and
then develop your own opinions based
upon that of those experiences because
there's a lot of oppression and
suppression specifically because culture
has been moving the same way for
hundreds and hundreds of years and great
change is he gonna come until we change
ourselves nice to all the boys I've
loved before let's talk about your
character in that you were playing kind
of like a fake boyfriend for half the
film Oh totally and then found love and
it was sOooo but you we loved it a
little bit um what is there anything in
particular with that character that is
relatable for you and you're really yeah
well you know falling in love with
someone when you don't think you're
going to that's totally something that I
think a few people can relate to
of course um this wasn't supposed to
happen and then it did just but also you
know Peter Peter I love the scene when
Lara Jean is afraid of love as she
expresses that he goes why like why are
you afraid to love yeah and I really I
really love that because you know I I
have to remind myself of that too